안녕하세요 시도입니다 다들 2025년
잘
시작하셨나요 저는 지난 달에 갈비뼈에
금이 가고 코로나인지 독감인지 모를
심한 감기가 찾아와서 난이도 상급에
연말을 보냈습니다 요몇주 계속 누워
있다가 목소리가 드디어 조금 돌아와서
찾아뵙게 됐습니다 다들 연말연시 건강
꼭 잘 챙기시기를 바랍니다
원래 제가 블로그에서 최근 구매
제품들을
리뷰했었던 느낌으로 진행해 보려
합니다 오늘은 제가 지난 연말 구매한
것 중 좀 잘 구매했다고 생각하고
겨울에 잘하고 다니고 있는 친구들을
소개해 드리려 합니다 바로 들어가
볼게요 첫 번째는 르메르의 이사 FW
랩 스카프입니다 제가 이번 겨울에
바라클라바 럼 쓸 수 있는 아이템을
찾고 있었어요 그래서 봤던 제품들이
익스트림 캐시미어의 위치 모델 그리고
자크 미스의 리샤 로그랑이 있었어요
그런데이 제품들은 직접 해보니까 좀
아담하고 귀여워서 저보다는 여성분들이
했을 때 잘 어울리는 제품
같더라고요 마땅한 걸 못 찾고 헤매던
와중에 한남 르메르를 갔는데 점장님이
이걸 하고 계신 거예요 봤는데 좀
무심하면서도 포인트도 되고 독이 너무
예쁘더라고요 그래서 어떻게 착용하는
건지 속성으로 배우고 구매까지
했습니다이 제품은 사실 이전에도 몇
차례 나온 적 있는 멜의 캐리오버
제품이에요 스카프의 존재 자체는 알고
있었는데 막상 구매까지 이어진 적은
없었어요 스카프를 처음에 그냥 봤을
땐 어떻게 착용해야 할지 감도 잘
않았습니다 끝부분은 소매의 단면처럼
생겼고 중간은 비대칭으로 생겨서
세모난 부분이 삐져나와 있어요 생긴게
이렇다 보니까 원하는 방식대로
다양하게 착용할 수 있다는 장점이
있습니다 먼저 가장 제가 많이 하고
다니는 방식인데 대충 중앙을 찾아
가지고 한쪽은 한 바퀴 반대쪽은 두
바퀴를 돌립니다 그리고 묶어요 그러면
스웨터를 두르는 것 같은 연출을 할
수가 있이 방식은 제가 스웨터나 우켓
같은 거 위에 두를 때 많이 하는
방식이에요 두 번째는 완전 방한용
방식입니다 이게 제가 제일 원했던
바라클라바 같은 방식이에요
일단 후드처럼 써주고 뒤로 돌리고
그리고 또 묶어줍니다
이건 코트 위에 입을 때 엄청 추울
때 하기
좋아요이 스카프가 좋은게 비대칭이
보니까 첫 번째 방식도 그렇고 두르게
되면 한쪽 어깨로 떨어집니다 뭐랄까요
좀 비정형적인 느낌이 다른 스카프에
찾아보기 쉽지 않다 보니까 꽤나
매력적으로 다가오더라고요
좀 하고 다니다가 더우면 후드를
내려주면 됩니다 요즘은 모자 썼을 때
이렇게 해보기도 하는데 약간 그
지드래곤 님이 하는 스타일링 같기도
하고 아무튼 예쁩니다
제가 이렇게 하는게 정답은 아니고
다양한 방법으로 할 수가 있는 정말
매력 있는
제품이에요 세 번째를 까먹을 뻔했는데
마지막은 아예 바지 위에다가 레이어링
하는 방식이에요 이건 집에서 해봤는데
밖게 하고 다녀본 적은 없어요 사실
점장님한테 어깨 놈으로 배운 거라
이게 맞는지도
모르겠습니다 이렇게 많이들 한다
이러시더라구요
[음악]
두 번째는 프라다의 이사 FW
브러시드 가죽 레이스업 슈즈입니다
작년 초 중순부터 패션 쇼들을 납작한
신발들이 많이 나오더라고요 뮤뮤 뉴
발란스도 그렇고 최근 프라다 쇼들을
나오는 신발들도 대부분 구미 났고
샤프하게
나왔습니다이 신발은 프라다의 쇼에도
나왔었어요 1번으로 굉장히 낮고 얼핏
보면 소이 어디지 할 정도로 굉장히
습니다 몇 달 전에 모델 김원중 님
유튜브에도 등장했던 신발인데 마침
탱고 꼬모에 입고돼서
구매했습니다 저는 최근에 이런 납작한
플랫한 신발이 좀 끌리더라고요 최근
트렌드 때문인지 아니면 제 취향의
변화인지 이제 큰 실루엣의 신발을
예전만큼은 잘 못 신게더 불과 몇
시즌 전까지만 해도 키한 신발들을
다들 많이 신 는데 말이죠 그래선지
제가 최근에 구매한 신발들은 다
굉장히 납작하고 발볼이
좁습니다이 신발은 정보가 너무 없어서
구매하기 전에 너무 구비 없고
착화감이 안 좋을까 봐 걱정을 많이
했어요 그런데 막상 받아 보니까
안쪽에 쿠셔닝이 있는 소리 들어
있더라고요 그래서 나름 굽도 있고
착화감도
편합니다이 신발은 단순한 굉장히
미니멀한 신발입니다
그래서 와이 치로 덮어 신으면 약간
그 고무신 같기도 해요 아직 어떻게
신어야 가장 이지를 고민
중입니다처럼 신으려면 좀더 레귤러한
실루엣 바지에 입어야 할 것 같은데
뭔가 제 스타일과의 중간 지점을 찾는
중이에요 다음은 르메르의 이사
하모니카 걸입니다
저는래 악세 를 거의 안 해요 목걸이
반지 뭐 팔찌 심지어 시계도 차는게
없어요 이유는 딱히 없는데 뭔가 그
답답한 느낌도 있고 매번 풀었다
채워야 해서 손이 잘 안
가더라고요이 목걸이는 위에 소개한 숄
스카프를 구매한 날 같이
구매했습니다 숄 스카프만 보고 결제를
하려는데 점장님이 프로님 이것도
예뻐요 하면서 제게 목걸이를 하나
보여 주는 거예요 목걸이를 제가
안에서
고민하다가 제 귀가 얇은 건지 아니면
점장님이 말씀을 잘하시는 건지
설득해서 구매하게 됐습니다 제가 정말
인생 처음으로 구매하고 착용하는
목걸이에요이 목걸이는 미니 하모니카로
돼 있습니다
1857년에 시작한 독일의 악기
제조사인 호너 협업에
만들었는데이 설명에 의하면 세계에서
가장 작은 하모니카 합니다
악기 업체와 함께 만든 제품이라서
실제로 볼 수가 있어요 가끔 자서
빌리조엘의 피아노맨 같은 거 틀어놓고
조금 따라해보기도 합니다 이건
부담스럽지 않은 포인트가 돼서 나름
자주하고 다녀요 목걸이 어디건지
질문도 몇 번 받고 하모니카 불어
달라는 요청받아서 물어보기도 하고
메르가 가방에 대중 시선이 많이
집중되어 있지만 들도 예쁘고
액세서리도 독특하면서 포인트 줄 수
있는게 많으니까 한번 보시는 걸
추천드려요 이번 시즌에도 액세서리들을
보면 다른 곳에서 좀 보기 어려운
독특하면서도 이쁜게
많습니다 제가 연말에 꼭 영상 많이
올려야지 하고
다짐했는데이 건강과 정신이이를
따라오지 못해가지고 애를 좀
먹었습니다 목소리도 지금 들어보니까
아직 다 안 나와서 상 퀄리티가 좀
걱정이 되긴 해요 올해는 좀 다양한
방법으로 소개와 인사를 드릴 수
있도록 잘 관리하고 준비를 해보도록
하겠습니다 오늘 제가 준비한 영상은
여기까지입니다 새해복 많이 받으시기
바라고요 늘 감사드립니다